大家好,我是来自英语社区的周艾辉
那么今天呢,我给大家带来英语架构盖览
本门课程主要分为两块点动
第一块是英语架构的一个盖览
第二块是英语架构的一个拆解
那么我们会详细介绍英语每一层和英语核心模块的定位
以及它的主要功能
那么首先呢,我们先介绍第一块点动,就是整个英语的架构
那么这张图呢,就是目前英语的架构
那么我们可以先从下往上看一下
那么最底层呢,是我们的硬件层
然后除了FPC GPU等正常的硬件之外呢
我们还支持可行之心环境的一些硬件
比如说Intel SJX
然后国产的海光CSV
然后Bob Marley之言的海边格雷尔等等
那么在硬件层之上呢,是我们的资源层
就英语的枯下这个平台
那包含了数据网络计算资源应用的管理
那么在资源层之上呢,是我们的计算层
那么大家可以看到,就是这里其实
英语包含了很多隐私保护计算的路线
那比如说多发年计算,统态,T1,T2,还有查分隐私,拖面啊等等
那么计算层之上呢,就支撑的是我们的算法了
那么比如说包含PSI,就隐私囚交,IPIR,逆动查询,然后数据分析
然后以及联邦学习等等
那么最上面呢,其实就是我们的产品层
然后其实主要包含白屏的产品
然后还有一些黑屏的一些API,SDK等等
那么右边呢,就是英语的一些通用的一些能力
比如说互联互通
那么核心其实就包含的是白核互联互通和黑核互联互通
然后另外一块内容是夸易观控
那么主要包含三全分质,密探传出,还有前站审计
那么云语的架构为什么长这个样子
就是为什么我们是这么分层的
那么我们有几个出发点吧
第一个出发点其实就是考虑到完备性的问题
就在目前我们看,就是整个隐私计算吧
它没有一个绝对优势的一个技术路线
所以你会看到云语支持很多技术
比如说统态啊,比如说多八年计算
比如提衣啊,差分隐私啊等等
那么第二个出发点是说
我们希望每一个分层呢,它都是一个
就是每一个,下面一层的分层
对上一层它是一个透明的
就是说我们希望每一个分层内部呢
它是一个刚内具的状态
那么层一层之间呢
我们希望它是一个地有合的状态
这样呢,我们希望开圆圆活可以
从那一层入手,开出去进行集成
那么第三个出发点呢
其实我们希望的是说
云语有更好的开放性
那么通过良好的分层的设计呢
我们希望不同的专业人员
可以在他自己的那一层里面呢
充分发挥他的专业优势
因为以自己算码设计到很多学科
那么接下来呢
我们会对整个云语的架构
进行一个拆解
然后会对每一个某块呢
进行一个更细致的讲解
那么首先我们介绍云语的产品
那么云语的产品呢
就是图中这个高亮的这一块了
然后其实归纳过来
其实就是包含的白屏
和黑屏的两大块那种
然后云语产品的定位呢
其实是通过可实化的产品呢
我们希望降低中单用户的体验
和掩饰的成本
就是说白就是
我们希望大家可以直接拿着云语产品
就可以进行做一个demo的掩饰
那么同时呢
我们会提供一些模块化的APN
然后希望可以让一些中间商去进行集成
那么云语产品的人情画像呢
其实我们这里列的非常多
就是包括集成商
包括需求
包括产品开发研发
其实我们那么就是
所有的关注云语的能
关注隐私保护计算
这个行业的人
其实他都可以关注一下云语的产品
因为这就是云语最直接的路口
第一个要介绍的是
云语的核心产品Secure Pad
然后这个是云语代表评划产品
Secure Pad提供了轻量化安装的体验
您通过Secure Pad可以快速体验云语的功能
同时云语提供了多种形态的部署
目前您看到的可能主要是中心模式
就是会有一个中心的平台
那么云语也会计划发布PUP模式
就是说每一个机构都会有一个独立的自己的平台
那么另外的云语的产品功能是很丰富的
会包含PC,包含TE,包含Circle
然后还有PSI等等
然后最后还要介绍一个云语的
特色的产品叫做Secure Note
就是您可以理解为它是一个具有Secure Flow特色的notebook
那么通过Secure Note
然后您可以直接进行一个交互式建模
然后可以在一个界面上管理多个机型的节点
那么接下来我们可以看一下
云语球交和逆动查询
就是PSI和PR
也就是图中这个高量的这一块
那我们先介绍一下PSI和PR的定义吧
PSI是Private Set Intersection的说息
那么其实PSI是一种特殊的安全多方计算协议了
那么它整个定义可以这么概括的理解吧
就是首先我们假设Alice持有X,即和X
那么Bob持有即和Y
那么Alice和Bob通过执行PSI协议
他们得到了X和Y的交集
那么除了X和Y的交集之外
不会泄露任何其他信息
这个就是PSI的定义
那么PR是Private Information Retriever的缩写
PR指的是用户查询
服务端数据的时候
服务端它不知道用户查的是哪些
那么在云语里面
PSI和PR的定位是说提供高性能
侵略化应用的专用协议模块
那么人群画像是PSI、PR的产品
需求和研发来研
那么云语PSI有这些特色吧
第一块是说这是非常丰富的协议吧
包括半程式模型和恶业模型
包括两方和多方
包括Unbalanced的PSI
那么另外云语的PSI在性能和协议上
都做了很多优化
其实目前在某些协议上其实是非常领先的
那么另外就是PSI提供了多层的路口
就是如果您是一个白屏用户
您可以直接使用PSI的产品
那如果您是一个开发人员
您可以通过seqflow接路
就是拍摄形式的方式接路
也可以直接用户的方式来继承
那么逆中查询PR的目前它的特色
其实有点类似
然后第一个它首先也支持很多种协议
目前只是sell的PR
就是label的PR
另外还计划支持一些更多的PR的功能
那么同时我们也对于有的PR
是做了一些协议和性能上的优化
另外就是PR我们也是计划提供多层路口的
就是如果您是开发人员
您可以通过seqflow或者库的形式去继承
如果您是白屏用户
我们这边也是计划
未来就是提供PR的产品
那么接下来我们介绍
三法层的数据分析这一块
那就屠龙高量的data analysis
那么目前予以的数据分析主要产品是seqflow
那么seqflow是secure collaborative
cure language的缩写
那么予以的seqflow是一种多方安全数据分析系统
那么可以让多个不限的参与方在保护
数据隐私的前提下
完成一个多方联合的数据分析了
那么seqflow的定位呢
其实就是说它我们希望的是说
屏蔽底层安全计算协议的复达性
同时提供很简单的seqflow语言
同样用户可以获得一个多方数据密带的分析能力
那么seqflow的类型画像
包含数据分析集成商
数据分析产品
数据分析需求还有研发能源
那我们看一下seqflow的一些核心特性吧
首先seqflow是
即一个半程式的安全模型假设
那么seqflow是只是多方的
同时提供了和买seqflow兼容的seqflow的方言语法
然后也支持常用的一些seqflow的功能算子
性能其实在多方安全计算这个定义的数据分析的话
是比较好的
同时还有些具有自己独特的一个数据使用
受捡管控的一个机制
然后也支持很多种的密带协议
然后也支持很多种的数据源记录
那么接下来我们可以看一下算法层的最后一块
那种联邦学习
联邦学习的定义是说
在原始数据不出狱的前提下通过交换
中间数据完成积极学习建模
那么云云的联邦学习其实保含两块
一块是水冰联邦
另一块是我们假的垂直联邦吧
那其实比较标准的定义是叫做
拆尾学习吧
接下来是spread learning的感觉
那么云云的联邦学习的定位是说
具备安全攻防保障的
明密文和积极学习框架和算法
它的人群画像
保含深度学习的需求方和产品的眼
然后也保含安全AI的研究人员
联邦学习的特色
保含安全攻防性能和算法的三大块
安全攻防保含安全风险度量体系
保含攻防的框架和算法
另外我们在性能这一块也做了很多优化
比如说吸入化、量化、流水线等等
然后算法这一块还是比较丰富的
比如说常见的音效算法
云云都有支持
还提供了很多sortar安全聚合的侧脸
另外联邦学习也会计划支持大模型
那么云云的计算层
我们首先看一下混合编译调度这一块
我们重点介绍一下refad
那么瑞是一个非常有名的分布式计算调度框架
那么云云也使用瑞
为什么还会有refad呢
首先fad是来自于联邦学习
就fad rate的单词的前三个字母
其实原因是说
云云一开始使用了瑞
但是我们在使用过程中发现
其实不仅仅是瑞
包括很多分布式调度框架
它面向的场景是一个机构内部的场景
但是隐私计算它面临的天然是一个跨机构的场景
这里会有不同
就是说你一个机构
被另一个机构去调度去管理
这个可能是不太容易被接受的
那也是因为这些原因
我们研发了refad
refad的定位市场
就是说它面向跨机构的场景
它提供两块核心的能力
一块是单个机构内的计算论物的独立调度能力
然后这个其实就是记忆瑞实现的
然后另一块是跨机构计算论物的协作能力
那这个是refad自己完成的
refad目前已经被瑞社区接受了
然后成了瑞的副画项目
那么需要关注refad的人群画像
可能是包含云云的工程的算法开发人员
就当您深度了解Civaflow底层的时候
可能会接受到refad的概念
那么后续我们也有专门的refad的课程
来介绍refad
然后
计算程的下面
我们会发现还有一大块神秘态引进
那么首先是spu
spu是secure process unit的缩写
就是英语的
密谈设备的最核心的一个模块之一
然后这个模块呢
我们已经发表了定会论文
然后并被usynix atr3给接受了
那么英语的spu的定位是说
乔接上层算法和底层安全协议
然后给大家提供原生的AI框架的体验
同时给用户提供透明的高性能的
密谈计算的能力
那么spu的能群画像呢
其实是说
机器学习开放研发能源
然后密码协议的研发能源
还有边缘器的研发能源
这里简单介绍一下spu的一个架构
那么spu的前端呢是
目前是以checks为主的
然后理论上也只是tentaflow和battlej
然后这两个还在进行中
那么中间层呢是spu的边缘器
然后首先呢会把前端边缘器
变成xla
然后xla会变成
机器学习的中间语源
然后这下层呢是spu的longtail
然后其实就是主要就是mpc的各种协议了
比如说sem2k,vy3还有chita
那么spu呢一些核心特性
第一个就是说
可以原生的对接主流的AI前端呢
那另外一个就是说性能比较好
然后做的数据变形优化呀
指令变形优化
那另外呢就是spu支持
比较丰富的mpc协议
那同时呢我们提供了非常好的协议扩展的接口
那其实这里其他就是一个非常好的例子
其他就是当时就是在
英语的这个spu的这个协议扩展的基础上
直接支持进来的
h1u呢是同态的加密设备
然后英语的h1u的定位是说
提供地门卡高性能的同态加密控
然后可以支持多内型扩展的设法协议
然后同时我们希望建立一个硬件加速的生态
那么h1u的人群好像呢
包含同态加密的用户
然后包括设法的研究人员啊
以及包括同态的硬件的研发人员
那么同态的一个原理呢
就是简单的介绍的话
就是说我们可以看左上边这张图了
就假如说s有两个数字
一个三一个五
那么他这三和五做了一个加密
得到一个密闻
他把密闻发给了Bob
那么Bob可以直接对这个密闻
做一个密台的加法
那么他得到一个介绍的c
那么之后把c返回给Alice
Alice对这个c做一个解密
然后他会得到一个正确的介绍是8
那么这就是一个同态加密的一个加法
那么同态加密的有些分类
就包含phe
就是说他支持密台的加法
或者获得的惩罚
那么lhe是说
支持有限制的密台加法和惩罚
注意是同时支持加法和惩罚
但是支持有限制
那么fhe就是说支持无限制
目前英语的h1u的核心的特性
包含
第一个是说
支持很多种的phe的算法
另外在性能这一块
我们是处于
越界领先的位置
另外h1u提供了
多种的接口
包括npilec的这种API
包括cij加python这两层的接口
同时还提供了
一部分的硬件加速的能力
接下来我们介绍
下一个密台引擎teu
teu是肯定资金环境单元的缩写
英语teu的定位是说
支持多种可信制型环境
具备数据使用
跨意管控能力的密台计算数据
然后提供的数据分析
机器学习
包括npclefl加速的等购
那么这一块关注的人群画像
是包括数据和规研究的音乐
te的软件开发的研
然后提供的硬件制造厂商
那么teu的特色
包含快语管控
然后快语管控的包含
数据确权
使用授权等等
那么会在货文的快语管控里面
会介绍的更多
那么同时英语的te
会提供很多可信的应用能力
包含语触领
包含经典机器学习
比如说Tatibus的建模
然后逻辑回规等等
然后也会提供
深度学习和大步行
这两个是计划快要发布的
然后同时呢
还会支持多种硬件
比如说SGX
iPhone 6
然后包括国产的海光CSV
和英特的TX
这些都是要支持的
然后下一个要介绍的是
计算层的密码源语
然后压口
那源语压口的定位呢
是说多种隐私计算路线
共同需要密码库
然后我们需要一个具备
安全实现保证
然后同时新人
高的一个库
那么它的轮群画像
是说安全密码的研究人员
那么这里重点提一下
为什么会有一个
云以自己的密码库
那么我们看一下现状
就写书界的密码库
存在的问题是说
第一个
它有些安全的实现并不标准
然后另外的性能
可能不是很好
还有一个就是
因为缺乏长期的维护
它的应用性
做的也不是很好
那么工业界的密码库
比如OpenSSL
那么第一个就是
它的新功能的
引动的比较慢
就是策略比较保守
另外它的应用性就是
可能也做的不是很好
就被它缺乏良好的
密码工具的抽象
那么因为这些事实
然后我们决定
做一个自己的密码库
然后这个密码库
压扣的定位
会有几个特色
一个是性能
性能很高
然后我们要传出
详细的benchmark
然后第二个是安全
然后压扣提供的算法
一定是经过广泛的验证和认可的
然后最后一块是
我们西洋应用性
做的很好
然后对于开发者
我们会提供联合的介绍抽象
同时我们也会提供
非常好的注释
那库下是云语的自愿管理层
那么包含数据管理
网络管理
计算自愿管理
和应用管理
那么库下定位是说
频率不同机构间
基础设施的差异
为跨机构写作
提供丰富前可靠的
自愿管理和任务调度能力
我们这里重点要强调一下
就是库下提供的是一个
通用的一个任务调度能力
也就是说
您不可以
您不只可以在库下
上面运行SeqFloor
您也可以在库下
上面运行其他的框架
比如说FIT
然后库下的关心的人群
可能是包含隐私保护
计算机成商
还有应为的开发论源
我们简单介绍一下
库下的架构
那么库下
它的新世纪Kabas
设计的
那么库下
会分为两大块钱
第一块是Must
Must里面核心的是一个K3S
其实是Kabas的一个
轻量发行板
然后在此之上
其实我们会实现了
很多库下自己的一些Controller
然后通过这些Controller
可以实现
跨意的任务调度
服务发现
数据授权等等
然后同时里面
还会有一个互联互通的
一个控制器
库下的另一块的
主要的概念是Light
节点这个概念
那么这里面有
三大块核心的那种
第一块是ServiceMesh
然后这个主要是
为了给不同的
转发动机之间
提供同一的
网络层基础
然后另外一个是DataMesh
然后就是说是给
数据管理
提供的基础设施
然后解决数据发现
多元适配
数据数据的问题
然后最后一个水减
现在主要是负责
节点实力的注册
核动机的管理
接下来我们介绍一下
云语的互联互通
云语的互联互通的
定位是说
我们希望是说
云语和其他厂商的平台
可以互联互通
然后共同完成一个
隐私计算的任务
然后它的认情画像
其实包含互联互通的
需求方算法的
研发认源
平台研发认源
同时也可以包含
隐私保护计算的基层商
互联互通的
主要包含两种模式
目前第一种叫做
黑色模式
然后又叫管理调度互联
它是什么意思呢
是说管理面
控制面其实是互联互通的
但是跑的算法容器是相同的
打个比方说
有两个机构
那他们的论务管理调度
实现是不一样的
但他们跑的都是sigflo
那么第二种模式
又叫做白河模式
它指的是说
你的算法本身
也是互联互通的
也就是说
你的跑的两边的算法
容器可能是不一样的实现
然后最后一块力浓
是快语管控
核心的概念是
三权分制面台成熟的
那么我们对快语管控的定义
是说
数据离开持有者的预知后
那么数据方呢
仍然可以有效的
控制数据的流转
就是避免数据被非法窃取
或者说被非法的使用
那么关注快语管控的呢
首先应该是
隐私保护计算的需求方了
数据方应该知道
这样才能确保
它的数据不会被滥用
然后另外一方面呢
我们也希望监管方
也可以关注这一块
因为你希望提供一个
快语管控的一个实践
然后希望给行业
做一个参考
那么之后呢
因为人员其实也可以关注这一块
快语管控的核心概念
是三权分制
那么三权是指数据资源持有权
那么它的对象呢
是数据资源了
那么数据加工使用权
它的对象是数据资源
以及数据资源
经过加工得到的数据产品
那么最后一个是数据产品经营权
那么它的对象呢
是数据产品
那么所谓的快语管控
这里核心要管的
其实就是数据加工使用
那么数据加工使用权的快语管控呢
一方面呢
我们需要通过合同
法律法规去约束
那另一方面呢
我们也需要通过技术去保障
那么云云呢
希望的是说
通过隐私计算作为核心呢
然后
构建一个密台的一个数连网
然后云云会提供
包括密台输牛
密台管道的能力
然后我们通过呢
对加工使用权的管控呢
然后充河支持
产品经营权的不失控
保证整个产品经营权的合理合法
最后呢
我们对云云的整个架构
做一个总结
那么前面呢
也介绍了云云的
很多层的一些
核心的定位呢
和它的特色
那么我们这里
我们再总结一遍
假如您是一个产品使用者
那么我们建议您关注云云的产品层
那么通过云云的白屏产品呢
您可以快速了解
和体验云云的能力
如果您是一个平台继承的
比如说您是一个中间渠道商
那么您可以继承云云的
开源框架比如说枯下
然后可以把云云的能力呢
包装成解决方案提供给客户
如果您是一个算法使用者
比如说您已经有自己的
隐私继承平台
有自己的调度能力
那么您可以关注一下
云云的算法
比如说联盟学习
也可以关注一下云云的
密探设备
比如说spu,hu,tu等等
然后在这些设备上
可以开发自己的算法
如果您是一个密码协议使用者
那么您也可以关注
云云的密码库压口
那么整个云云呢
它是基于一个完整
透明和开放的原则
来进行设计的
那么我们希望每一层呢
它都是一个高内聚
层与层之间地有合
这样一个状态
然后每一层呢
都可以用户
可以轻易地去集成
然后可以单独使用
那么本门课程
其实目标也是这个
就是希望大家通过本门课
了解云云每一层的作用
然后当你进到云云
这个非常大的框架的时候
可以快速知道
自己应该去了解哪一块
从哪一层进行入手
那么课程到此结束
感谢您的观看